I often got real physical headaches
while playing abduction towards the end
of the game I'd regularly get completely
stuck when trying to solve a puzzle I
decide I was missing something vital to
its solution and proceeded to run back
and forth through the game's huge world
searching every area multiple times eyes
glued to the screen I take a wrong turn
in a thick forest retrace my steps get
lost again and then get mad at myself
but when I eventually did stumble upon
that missing link whether it be an
obscured set of stairs or a line in a
book I'd previously dismissed the pieces
fell into place and my frustrations all
been disintegrated I'd unwelcome and
just agait the soundtrack would swell
and I discover a breathtaking new region
full of fresh difficult puzzles created
by the same developers behind classic
adventure games mist and ribbon
abduction presents an eerie world filled
with tough puzzles to solve an
intriguing law to uncover at the start
of the game you're transported to an
area that's immediately stunning and
perplexing rocky desert mountains matted
with distinct American Architecture from
throughout history an Old West frontier
town a 1950s gas station and a graffiti
rail yard while this initial
sun-drenched area fills invitingly warm
on first glance there's also an
underlying sense of otherworldly Menace
distant horizons aligned with enormous
purple crystalline formations in
floating islands the occasional waft of
tense violins in the soundscape lends
the familiar architecture and off-kilter
slant real world actors betrays strange
characters in odd hologram messages and
every part of that feels a little out of
place and even though you seem to be
alone the bizarre nature of environment
stops you from feeling in control
abduction emphasizes play discovery and
while you're given some broad direction
in the beginning it quickly falls away
abduction doesn't draw attention to its
obstacles there's no strict order of
progression and its puzzles are hidden
in plain sight as part of the
environment key items aren't highlighted
by default and only reveal themselves as
interactive objects once you get close
enough in order to both discover and
solve problems you're required to scour
the meticulously detailed world to find
levers switches cryptic clues narrative
details ciphers
and other useful items characteristic of
abductions routes in the Miss series
it's the games encouragement for
discovery that makes puzzles fun and
it's their complex mechanical nature
that makes them so satisfying to
decipher abductions obvious calls often
involved in deflating physical objects
and contraptions punching buttons to key
in a code or dragging your mouse to pull
a lever gives each step in a puzzle
solution of pleasing tangible quality
rumbling iron gears and mysteriously
high-tech gates make for a wonderful
audio-visual reward on top of the
gratification that comes from resolving
a tricky puzzle
however abduction is unrelenting its
lack of player assistance and some
solutions are more obscure and obtuse
than others while you have the option to
make some objects glint unnaturally King
you into their importance some clues are
purely visual and provide no indication
of how they might interact with other
clues if at all in every case it's
completely up to you to connect the dots
and figure out how an object or clue
might be useful it can be invigorating
to have a sudden breakthrough and rush
to test your theory but the process can
also be incredibly draining I frequently
felt stumped or completely baffled but
this depends on how observant you may or
may not be at the time this direction
this feeling does initially has the
mystique of the game's first half when
locations are mostly undiscovered you
like a holistic understanding of how the
world works new discoveries are
especially magical at this point in time
because they're full of unknowns but
challenges become increasingly difficult
and complex and the lapse in patience or
observation can lead to fatal gaps in
your knowledge of the worlds logic which
can take a painful amount of time to
identify and ultimately resolve one
overlooked clue can completely halt your
momentum and cost you large amounts of
time making rewarding successes fewer
and further between in its final hours
abduction introduces intricately grand
puzzles that involve environmental
manipulation and travelling between
different interconnected locations at
predetermined points although clever
these scenarios often require a large
amount of backtracking and the endurance
to withstand a collection of learning
screens as you travel back and forth a
process that grows increasingly
exhausting because of the size of the
game's world and the numerous mechanisms
that can
strict access to certain routes getting
lost while backtracking can also become
a very real frustration and increased
chances of missing vital clues this is
an experience that requires you to play
with patience but there are times when
your best intentions aren't enough
although you may feel at odds with
abductions late-game complexity it still
feeds into an incredibly alluring world
that earns intimate engagement its
puzzles require keen observation and
perseverance and while player made
missteps can lead to mental fatigue
abductions commitment to keeping the
owners of discovery on you means that
deciphering the game's intricate puzzles
is often gratifying despite occasional
frustrations along the way just make
sure to take breaks and clear your head
once in a while
[Music]